everybody has the fear of failure the
fear of something of the unknown and
last minute you don't do it and then you
say I'm really gonna do this and you do
it again and again after a while you
don't want to disappoint yourself so you
might develop a new identity and say I'm
a procrastinator
and once that's who you are that
behavior is going to be consistent it is
that powerful a control system on how we
function as human beings so anything you
attach the words I am to over and over
again consistency with your language
with your emotion with an emotional
intensity you'll eventually become it
because it becomes a belief and a belief
is self-fulfilling whether you think you
can whether you think you can't you're
right you know so often people say I'm
not that kind of person what kind of
person and when did you define yourself
a year ago five years ago ten years ago
20 years 30 years ago most people was a
long time ago and maybe at the end of
this conversation it's time to update
your sense of identity maybe it's time
to expand it maybe it's time to take
some of the labels off that might limit
you maybe it's time to look at some that
you want to Define Yourself by As you
move for the next five or ten years of
your life of growth and expansion
self-esteem does not come from what
people say about you self-esteem comes
from what you experience about yourself
see someone tell your whole life you're
a piece of crap and a part of you go
you're full of it I'm gonna show you
lots of people have done that they never
bought it
or someone tell you you're beautiful
your whole life you go I'm not really
beautiful
so what people tell you it doesn't
matter at all it's what you stack it's
what you assemble it's what you create
it's the habit of what you put in your
head there are situations where people
get in a certain emotional state they're
scared they're angry they're afraid
they're whatever and they behave a
certain way
but if they do that several times they
might say that's the kind of person I am
and once you do it's self-fulfilling or
worse you know somebody and they were
mean to you sometimes there are they're
such a mean harsh person well I bet
they're different with their child I bet
they're different when they're not under
stress but so when we give somebody an
identity we limit our ability to
actually reach that Soul or that spirit
and we limit our own world and we put
ourselves in a place of Judgment of
others and we're judging others who's
the first person we're gonna judge
ourselves
people get vested in their trauma people
get vested in their pain if you want to
know the largest drug on the planet it's
not you know some prescription drug the
biggest you know drug on the planet is
problems because everyone has a deep
fear everyone in the deepest fears we
have are two one is that we're not
enough
we're not smart enough young enough Rich
enough pretty enough funny enough
something enough
and if we're not enough against the
deepest fear we have which is we won't
be loved and love is the oxygen the soul
because as human beings if you get in
your head you're dead almost all of us
can find something to be upset about
that's the nature of the mind you need
something that gets you to move forward
and like I feel so bad for the
generation today you know Z generation
Millennials because so many of them are
now talking about not even having
children because of the exaggeration of
the problems we've always had problems
and we've always learned to adapt to
these challenges whatever those
challenges may be but people today think
these problems are forever because we've
had some times here that we've never had
where we literally shut down the whole
world and had people trapped in their
homes and that has an effect on people
because they don't have a compelling
future and it's got to be a compelling
future about more than just getting by
that's not compelling or surviving or
doing okay you know the secret to anyone
who succeeded is they found something
they care about more than themselves
people make these generalizations
because they don't understand how human
behavior and how the human mind works
would you understand there's only so
many patterns you can start to identify
a pattern and then the second step is to
start to use it instead of letting it
use you stress is a pattern you either
use stress or uses you as an example and
then you get really good you're good at
creating patterns and that's when you
become really masterable so we pay
attention to a small amount of things so
if you're really happy you're deleting
all the things that could piss you off
or make you worried if you're really
worried you're deleting all the things
you could be grateful or happy about so
and we tend to generalize Our Lives
because we're cognitive misers we don't
want to think things through so if you
have strong physiology strong Focus then
the third piece is meaning is what
creates emotion if somebody says
something and you go they're
disrespecting me or they're challenging
me or they're coaching me or they're
loving me
well whichever word you select for those
Sensations in your body your
biochemistry becomes and so you know
somebody might say oh you know this
happened to me because God's punishing
me or this happened to me because God's
challenging me or there's problems here
because it's a gift from God or someone
else says it has nothing to do with God
it's the fact that I've been a lazy
bastard right whatever it is you do in
your head there is a biochemical effect
so there's the body there's the focus
and there's language those three shape
how you feel moment to moment so many
people that are abundant that are angry
all the time because their anchors
they're not growing I know some people
are not a good influence I'm not denying
that I'm just saying you're more than
somebody's influence unless you obsess
about it every moment and make them
wrong so you can make yourself feel
Superior morally psychologically or
spiritually and stop the pattern we've
all done it catch yourself because if
you want joy happiness and freedom and
extraordinary life you will not come
from blame never there's no Pride that
comes from blame I don't mean fake Pride
will you make to feel good I'm talking
about real pride pride is something you
earn like unless you expand your
identity you're going to basically keep
where you are you might improve a little
or not you might go up and down a bit
but you're going to stay within a realm
if you're gonna have an explosive
breakthrough to another level physically
mentally financially spiritually then we
gotta not only give you the tools we
gotta shift that internal sense of who
you really are and have you find that
you are more than anything that's ever
happened to you that you can handle
whatever shows up even if it's
incredibly scary or uncomfortable we all
have a life story right some people's
life is a warning some people's life is
an example so what I'm looking for is
what's their story and the story is
driven by number one what's their desire
if you go to a movie read a book in the
first few minutes the main character
you'll discover what their desire is it
to merge with God is it to find a great
relationship and have children is it to
free themselves from being enslaved or
whatever it is there's a driving desire
and then there's always as soon as you
have a desire there's a problem because
otherwise you have your desire and the
problem usually is character peace is
missing within yourself you're being
selfish you're not giving enough you're
not creative enough you're not trusting
enough something enough and then as you
go through the story of a person's life
what happens is plan doesn't work you
end up having battles and the battles
invariably are with external enemies
with intimate enemies like who can hurt
you more the person you don't know or
the person you love who seems to
betrayed you and then there's the
internal enemy the conflicts within
yourself and as you fight through the
those battles if you continue to grow
you come to a point where you have
insights you see what the real truth is
it isn't somebody else it's me this is
what needs to shift and if you see that
and act on it kind of jump through the
opening so to speak then life's never
the same again or life is happily ever
after because you've made a shift in the
core values and beliefs and emotions
that are driving your life there's
something inside you that's bigger than
anything that's ever happened to you
that ever could happen to you and
tapping in and finding that part of
yourself is how you get someone to have
sustained strength the mind is
constantly dissecting things separating
comparing but when you look at it back
and you take a look at somebody's life
and you look at the totalitarian aspect
of what am I here to serve what am I
here to give what am I being called to
for life so identity and compelling
future are the ultimate things that
shape people if you're not doing it you
don't own it you don't experience it so
I'm a big believer in immersion where
someone has to grow where it's not a
should grow it's a have to grow there's
no choice but all of this fear has put
people in a place where there's no
compelling future and that's one of the
things that we all need we can all deal
with the difficult today if we have a
compelling tomorrow so everybody's got
to find it is what it is that they
really love but the skills you got to
master you have life on your terms is
one the science of achievement that's
what you're describing how to take what
I Envision and make it real and those
are strategies and they are proven
strategies there are certain rules of
the game if you want to be healthy and
you want a lot of energy everyone's
biochemically slightly different but
there's certain rules if you violate
them you're gonna have low energy and
disease if you align with them you've
got an enormous energy and strength same
thing around Finance anyone can grow
financially but most people don't learn
the basic fundamentals and so they
missing the strategy so that's strategy
driven and I spend a good portion of my
life teaching people that but then the
second part is what creates lasting
fulfillment if we're not making progress
or not happy but the really ultimate
formula besides progress is appreciation
because you can make progress and then
it'll always have to make progress each
moment to be happy happiness only
requires that you are grateful if you've
got a billion dollars and three
beautiful children that love you and a
beautiful husband or wife but doesn't
matter what you have if you're not
grateful if you live in an emotional
home a habitual pace of worry or
frustration your life's called worry and
frustration so it's you could be making
progress and still be worried and
frustrated I look at my own life and I
said that's what I want to continually
do and it's a never-ending process of
saying how do I keep pushing myself
people go through different stages of
life in your birth to 20 is one stage of
life and everyone has a different stage
but you're primarily receiving
information learning growing 21 to let's
say 41 is you're the soldier of society
now you go test what you were taught you
think you're Invincible you're going to
be a billionaire ten times over you can
have ten thousand businesses and then
you learn things are more complex in one
relationship than you could ever imagine
and you're not invincible and so you
learn in that time period and that's a
time period of a lot of stress for a lot
of people trying to figure out how to
make it work if you work hard in the
spring and the summer so to speak and
now you come to fall 43 to 63 that's a
power period because you've accumulate
enough relationships insights strengths
skills tools if you've grown that you
now can really begin to have a reaping
time in your life and then 63 to 83 or
103 the oldest living people go to 120
is kind of the final stage and that
winter time is your chance to really be
a mentor because at that stage you don't
worry about yourself you're not judging
yourself so much you know who the hell
you are
foreign